[Music]
i needed to get my life purpose after
being wrongfully incarcerated for 17
years
i was illiterate i couldn't read at the
time but when i started to learn how to
read it changed my life and it actually
put me in a position to be empowered
enough to win a fight for my innocence
and for my freedom
my name is john bunt and i help promote
literacy in schools and prisons
when i was 14 years old i was wrongfully
accused and convicted of a crime i had
no knowledge of i had nothing to do with
it led to me being incarcerated for 17
years
and then on parole for another 10 years
which was a total of 27 years for me
fighting for my life
in the beginning stages i was under the
impression that the system was going to
come to my aid because i was an innocent
man
the deep i went into my incarceration
the hope started to fade away when i
went to trial my lawyer told me any
questions or anything i had to write it
down on a piece of paper
and i sat there and couldn't write
anything because i didn't know how to
read and write so it's like i sat there
and watched my whole life flash before
my eyes
so it like ignited a fire into me to
learn how to read
when i was in prison there was a teacher
there that started showing me how to
sound words out and taking special
interest in me giving me dictionaries
and children books to get me over the
barrier
the process of learning took about 18
months
reading was definitely a positive
experience for me it still is to this
day
i found that there was a lot of guys
that had this literacy issue because of
my ability to read and write i was able
to help out other inmates and enhance
their abilities
[Music]
in 2018 i was able to get that wrongful
conviction fully exonerated for my
record and now my life has a new leaf
when i actually got released i started a
voice for the unheard which is a
literacy program
it started out as a book drive i
collected over 80 000 books and i
distributed books to everywhere you can
imagine from youth detention centers to
ragdos island to boys clubs to community
centers
today we're about to donate thousands of
books to friends of island academy for
them to be able to distribute and
they're going to also start a new
library in a hub
friends of ireland academy is a
non-profit organization offering
advocacy support and services to age 16
to 21 year old youth affected by the
criminal justice system
i met john bunn and immediately i mean
just connecting to his story and so when
i sat down with him i just felt his
passion his sincerity it wasn't a hustle
it was something that was really on his
heart to give to young people and to
really utilize literacy as a tool to
connect
literacy is freedom
freedom of your mind it's like you
unlock your mental chains your mind get
that the privilege to monitor the four
corners of the earth
it's magical to me to be in a position
to be privileged able enough to do
something positive
that's priceless
[Music]
you